Mo-Mo-Mo-Mo-MonkaW
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich.
Moin, ihr seid aber schon früh hier am Start.
Stream ist das erste Mal seit 50 Sekunden.
Online.
Ja, es ist, was haben wir noch? Donnerstag.
Donnerstag, 12.39 Uhr.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so wenig gestreamt wie am Donnerstag um 12.39 Uhr.
Ich glaube, da habe ich keine Ahnung, ob ich da jemals schon gestreamt habe.
Bestimmt irgendwann mal, keine Ahnung.
Ja doch, doch, Dezember, im Dezember irgendwann.
Heute keine Arbeit.
Ne, ich wurde gezwungen Urlaub zu nehmen.
Ja, ist so.
Ja, scheiße.
Ähm, ich wurde gezwungen,
Urlaub zu nehmen, Leute.
Ich hab noch vier
Resturlaubstage
aus 2025.
Und ich hab gestern
mit der Vertretung von meinem Chef
darüber geredet und hat gemeint, ja, wie?
Ähm, dann
musst du jetzt einfach
daheim bleiben. Habe ich gesagt, wie, jetzt einfach so?
Ja, ist ja gut, wenn du das sagst, dann mache ich das.
Dann bleibe ich daheim.
Und dann bin ich daheim geblieben.
Warum nicht?
Und er hat gemeint, wenn sich irgendwelche Projekte beschweren, dass ich nicht da bin,
dann kann er mir sogar offiziell eine Anweisung schreiben, die ich denen geben kann.
sagt, guck hier, mein Chef sagt,
ich soll daheim bleiben.
Sagt, ja, ja, wird nicht notwendig sein,
aber wenn du das sagst, dann mach ich das. Ich hab da
keine Schmerzen mit, daheim zu bleiben.
Ja, weil das Ding ist,
Ende März verfallen die Restarbeits-,
äh, die Resturlaubstage
vom letzten Jahr. Das ist natürlich
doof.
Wenn die verfallen.
Um nicht zu sagen,
das sackt.
Das sackt richtig.
Siehste?
Verfällt das bei dir auch,
wenn du es jetzt nicht nimmst?
Ahja, und auf deine...
Verfällt nicht? Achso, ja dann.
Ich hab gedacht, du musst das jetzt auch nehmen.
Netzwerkkarte, die Netzwerkkarte im Nass,
Leute, das Ding geht mir so
auf den Sack.
Das ist ja eine richtig gute Hardware.
Von der Zusammenstellung und vom Stromverbrauch und so kannst du nichts sagen.
Aber diese Netzwerkkarte, die ist so dermaßen beschissen.
Ich zeige euch das auch gleich.
Ich habe das NAS jetzt bei mir hinten ins Rack gestellt.
Da, wo es eigentlich stehen soll.
Ich habe es angeschlossen an den Switch.
Und auf einmal hatte ich nur noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 5 bis 6 Gigabit.
Einfach so, random.
An dem anderen Switch hier, als es auf dem Tisch gestanden hat
Hatte ich noch
8,5 bis 9,5
Einfach so, random
So, und dann bin ich auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal so, wie jeder Kack-Noob
Ähm, und das unter Windows machen würde
Ich installiere den offiziellen
Herstellertreiber mit den Default-Settings
Und dann hatte ich zwischenzeitlich, keine Ahnung
15 Mbit oder so
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Was diese Netzwerkkarte für ein Problem hat
Warte mal
Ich muss aber meine Linux-Kiste einschalten, dann kann ich es euch zeigen.
Das Ding ist wirklich...
Also die Netzwerkkarte ist so krass für den Arsch.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Hätte ich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass eine Netzwerkkarte so krass für den Arsch sein kann,
wie das Teil, was da drin ist.
Ich meine, das Gute ist,
das Ding hat einen PCI-Express-Slot.
Das heißt, ich könnte da jederzeit einfach irgendwas anderes reinstecken.
Irgendeine Internet-Netzwerkkarte oder sowas.
Irgendwas, wo man weiß, das funktioniert ordentlich.
Aber das kann es doch nicht sein.
So, und heute probieren wir das mal aus.
Ich werde heute es an meinem 10-Gig-Switch probieren, der im Rack hängt.
Ich werde es an dem Switch probieren, der hier am Basteltisch steht.
Dann werde ich noch ein Update machen von dem Switch.
ähm
und dann müssen wir das mal systematisch
durchgehen, mit welchen Settings, ich gehe
nach Ort einmal ins BIOS, in dem BIOS
stellen wir mal die
ähm, Strom sparen für die
Netzwerkkarte aus, vielleicht bringt das irgendwas
das müssen wir mal systematisch durchgehen
und gucken, woran es jetzt
eigentlich liegt, weil mich fuckt das echt
massiv ab, dass die Netzwerkkarte
so rumspinnt
ähm
Vielleicht soll ich mal kurz den PC einschalten, bevor ich jetzt hier einfach auf No Signal stehen lasse.
Tja, viel Spaß.
Lukas, es hindert dich keiner dran, dir Sachen reinzustecken, wenn du Spaß dran hast.
Oh, ist das jetzt ordentlich gesta...
Ah, ne, Moment, Passwort muss ich noch eingeben.
Massive, kommen die nie drauf.
Fünfstelliges Passwort ist auch highly secure, sind wir uns einig, oder?
Also ich glaube, viel securer als ein fünfstelliges Passwort kann es gar nicht mehr werden.
Dragon Soul, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
Massive Pog Subscription.
Ne, es ist ja sogar ein.
Excellent.
So, zack.
Da sind wir auf unserer Linux-Kiste.
Pepo happy.
Die Uhrzeit stimmt nicht so ganz.
Mir fällt gerade auf, ich habe
mein Hintergrund
Skript noch gar nicht
automatisch
gestartet, was die
was die
Hintergrundbilder.
Genau, weil eigentlich brauchen wir ja ein Bild
vom Tag, tagsüber.
Die letzten Comments beim Treiber sind sieben Monate alt.
Nee.
Nee, es gab...
Du meinst jetzt von der Realtek-Karte?
Das ist Massive Rare Stream, ja.
Ohne F-Programmer hast du schon eine Katze adoptiert.
Und mein Debian hat einen Treiber dafür?
Wirklich?
Ach nee, du meinst den.
du meinst diesen rr 8196 oder sowas oder real tech ach der das ist der falsche
Das ist der falsche. Das ist eine R127. Die R125 ist die Gigabit-Karte, glaube ich.
so und und also offizielle hersteller treiber gibt es hier von anfang märz im
kölner treiber sind ist die 10 gig netzwerkkarte seit glaube ich linux
kernel 6.5 10 und die steht sogar ab zu 6.5 was halt was halt blödsinn ist weil
ja genau das ist der richtige r8 127 dk ms den habe ich den habe ich tatsächlich drauf den
habe ich tatsächlich drauf installiert hier minis minis form geht ab falls wir irgendwie
finden gott hab hier was soll ich nehme ich nehme einfach das kann ja nicht sein
aber minis forum geht geht hab ich jetzt blöd war ich da noch nie drauf hier wir
haben das doch zusammen ist doch genau und die haben die haben auch noch den
alten treiber nicht hier von anfang märz also das packt messes backt es rum
So, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich verbinde mich mal kurz auf mein NAS.
Ah, Chat.
Vielleicht sollte ich so schlau sein und es erstmal einschalten, oder?
Bevor ich mich drauf verbinde.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken. Ich habe mir nämlich schon Notizen aufgeschrieben.
Ah, ich brauche noch ein Netzwerkkabel.
Ein bisschen längeres.
Dass ich von dem einen Switch zu dem anderen Switch hinkomme.
Also besser gesagt, von dem Standort, wo das nass ist, zu dem anderen Switch hinkomme.
Da brauche ich mal so ein 3-4 Meter Kabel.
Wo habe ich denn? Warte mal.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall ein ganz langes noch.
Wisst ihr, was mir auch einfällt?
Vielleicht liegt es auch am Kabel.
Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt erst einmal.
Und dann gucken wir uns das an.
woran es denn jetzt letztendlich liegt als ich gesagt nervt mich schon richtig
ich gehe mal kurz die wir kurz mal das einschalten bin in zehn sekunden wieder
da
Da bin ich wieder.
Ja.
magst du würdest du für ein os mittlerweile empfehlen android tuners oder was sagen gutes
mittelding aber das ist so es gibt eigentlich keins wo ich sagen würde also ab tuners gucken
wir uns demnächst an da habe ich kein aktuelles know how was das angeht das letzte mal wo ich
wir tun was angeht angeguckt habe da war dem ihre container geschichte noch auf
irgendeiner kuban ist das ganz merkwürdig das kann ich nichts zu sagen aber aber
insgesamt muss ja irgendwie gefällt mir keins so gut dass ich sagen würde will
das in dem discord moment moment bekomme ich muss ich muss katzen bilder gucken
das ist nicht wieder das ist wichtig nur kurz discord ich copy paste es euch auch
hier hin oder max hat was geschrieben freund was ist da eine discord hängt
obwohl es will expire in seven days okay du hast recht soll ich vielleicht
machen
bei der max wir hast du diesen check gemacht kann abzeiten kuma mittlerweile
hues informationen passen oder sowas oder wie hast du das gemacht mit dem
domain check
rf programmer in welchem hier bilder
ok
q chat
ach ja
ich moment moment das niedliche niedliche katzis guck mal hier hat der
copy image an dem moment copy link muss ich machen copy link hat der
AF-Programmer gepostet hier.
Außer Türkei.
Ganz viele Katzis unterwegs.
Warte mal, das Bild gibt es
auch noch in größerer Auflösung.
Weiße Katzis.
Wuppet.
Da sind aber auch viele unterwegs.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Die weiß schon, warum sie da davor sitzt, oder?
Die wartet, bis man sie rein darf.
Und dann haben wir noch...
Die hier.
Ja.
Ja, in der Türkei gibt es viele Katzis, ne?
Mehr Katzen als Leute, ja.
Ja, das wäre was für mich, ja.
ich mache das ich mache das wenn ich mit dem stream fertig spinnen wird
es ist nicht nur wupplos max fps tv ist auch expired auch glaube ich
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
So.
Okay, also, auf geht's.
Gehen wir mal hier rüber.
Zack.
Loggen wir uns mal auf den Last ein.
Sollte jetzt hochgefahren sein.
So, also.
Die Netzwerkkarte, Leute.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, wo ich echt nicht schlecht gestaunt habe.
Ich installiere mal wieder den...
Install.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das die Variante ist, die ich installieren muss, dass das rumspackt.
jetzt erleben wir den netzwerk 3 barry bote das ding wir gehen hier hin wir machen schon
mal ein paar fan cd desktop ipad ipad so zack beim mal gucken also also guck mal aktuell habe
ich Netzwerkkartentreiber
11.015
drauf.
Jetzt habe ich gerade den 16er installiert,
aber noch ist der aktiv.
Ups, vielleicht soll ich auch mal
hier reinwechseln. Also machen wir mal iPerf.
So, da wird euch jetzt gleich
schon auffallen.
Ups, äh.
Da wird euch jetzt gleich schon auffallen,
irgendwie sackt
die Geschwindigkeit richtig krass, ne?
also keine ahnung warum das nur bis über 5 mbit hat aber irgendwie sagt ich kann euch übrigens
auch zeigen dass das prinzipiell okay ist ja wenn man jetzt mal hingehen sagt hier etf tool
dann sieht man auch es ist gesünd also netzwerk speed ist zehn gig also das nicht dass ich aus
versehen die fünf gigabit karte verwendet haben ich habe schon die zehn gigabit karte verwendet
Aber irgendwie spackt das richtig heftig rum.
So.
Witzigerweise, wenn man die andere Richtung testen lässt, dann...
Äh, ups.
Sollte jetzt nochmal iPerf starten.
Alter, ich bin gerade voll verwirrt mit meinen Hotkeys.
Wenn ich in die andere Richtung gehe, dann ist es stabile 1,15 Gig.
Da denkst du schon, hä?
Was ist das?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
so jetzt wird rebootet mit der neuesten netzwerkkarten treiber version und die
war einfach nur super schlecht also ich meine 55 bis 6 gig ist ja schon mies
bei einer 10 gig karte mit ipad aber das was jetzt gleich kommt ich hoffe das ist
die richtige version ansonsten muss ich noch mal schnell kompilieren euch zeigen
Was jetzt gleich kommt, ist nochmal, das setzt dem die Krone auf.
Wollen wir kurz warten, bis das Ding rebooted ist.
Geht aber glücklicherweise relativ zackig.
Es macht mich fertig mit der Netzwerkkarte.
Egal was ich mache, irgendwas ist immer.
Was ich nochmal ausprobieren kann,
wie gut die Netzwerkkarte ist mit dem Original-Treiber aus dem Körnel.
Was hast du da für eine Netzwerkkarte?
Ich habe die Onboard-Netzwerk-Karte von dem NAS.
Das ist eine Realtek RTL 8127.
Also relativ neu.
Ist auch erst im Kernel seit 6.15 der Support.
Ich verwende aber mittlerweile gar nicht mehr den Treiber im Kernel,
sondern den offiziellen Herstellertreiber.
Das macht es zwar, oder hat es zwar etwas, am anderen Switch,
hat es zwar etwas besser gemacht,
aber auch nicht gut.
Es ist wirklich Hardcore-Upfuck, sag ich dir.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt auch iPerf.
Das ist jetzt Treiber.
Kann ich euch zeigen.
Guck.
Up, Search.
Ah, nee.
DKMS kann jetzt so ein 8127.
Guck, da habe ich jetzt 016 die Version.
So, iPerf.
Gucken wir jetzt mal.
Reverse.
Geschwindigkeit okay, wie vorher.
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich bestimmt das Falsche.
Okay, immer noch der gleiche Mist wie vorher, nur noch ein bisschen schlechter.
Also es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, was ganz furchtbar hier ist.
Wenn ich mal teste von hier, von dem Server aus, gegen eine andere 10G-Kiste, die ich bei mir lokal stehen habe,
dann...
Jetzt ist es aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder schneller.
das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
The fuck?
Naja, so wirklich gut ist es nicht.
Und wenn ich aber
nicht, dass ihr denkt, das liegt jetzt irgendwie
an meiner Kiste hier. Wenn ich von hier
auf die andere Kiste gehe,
dann ist auch alles top.
Dann ist auch kein Problem. Also es kann nicht
an der Netzwerkkarte oder auf dem Weg dahin liegen,
weil zu dem anderen Host,
guck hier, zu dem anderen Host ist es vollkommen okay.
das ist die Netzwerknatte, die hier rumspackt.
So, und jetzt, pass mal auf,
jetzt gehen wir mal
hier rein, DKMS
Treiber, stell's.
Und jetzt mache ich mal alles
default, alles default in dem
Makefile, okay?
Für den Netzwerktreiber.
Das ist default und
das ist default.
So, uninstall.
Lösch ich das Ding, installiere es wieder
Und jetzt wird es gleich richtig beschissen
Also hardcore beschissen
Mit den Default Settings
So, was ich jetzt nämlich mal ausprobieren will ist
Ich will im BIOS mal
Diese Stromspar-Sachen
Für die Netzwerkkarte ausschalten, falls das geht
Und mal probieren
Wie das an dem Switch ist, wenn ich
Ein Modul verwende
Also ein
SF4 Plus auf AR45 Modul, anstatt
direkt einen AR45 Stecker zu stecken.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich mit der Netzwerkkarte noch machen soll.
Install.
Jetzt müssen wir leider wieder
rebooten.
Also wir müssten nicht, ich konnte
jetzt auch die KVM anschließen und
Kernelmodul
entladen, neu laden, aber wir rebooten mal.
Das dauert ja bloß 20 Sekunden oder so.
Also ganz wirres Zeug.
Und jetzt, also wenn ich
jetzt das Richtige installiert habe, dann werdet ihr mal sehen,
die Performance ist komplett
unterirdisch.
Ich meine, bei einer 10-Gig-Karte
iPerf,
5 bis 5,7 Gig
ist auch schon unterirdisch. Aber jetzt
werdet ihr gleich mal massive
unterirdisch schlechte Performance sehen.
Die ist richtig schlecht.
im Mbit-Bereich.
Zumindest hatte ich das das letzte Mal.
Das Dumme ist, die Sachen sind auch nicht immer 100%ig
nachvollziehbar. Manchmal
ist es so, manchmal nicht. Also wie gesagt,
ich schiebe das komplett auf die Netzwerkkarte,
weil mit anderen Netzwerkkarten
am gleichen Switch zwischen
meinem Desktop-Rechner
kein Problem. Alles top.
Das liegt an dieser Kack-Real-Tech-
Netzwerkkarte. Ich sag's euch.
So, IPerf.
Starten. Zack.
So.
Okay, ist immer noch so schlecht.
Es ist noch schlechter, guck mal, es ist noch schlechter.
Jetzt blicke ich aber gar nicht mehr durch, weil das letzte Mal war ich im Mbit-Bereich.
Mal versucht, Windows auf dem Nass zu puten und den Windows-Treiber getestet.
Habe ich nicht.
Wenn man aber Reddit glaubt, dann ist es deutlich besser unter Windows.
der windows treiber soll wohl soll wohl eine ganze ecke besser sein von will tech
aber bringt mir halt nichts
das ist vor allem es kommt es ist noch schlechter geworden jetzt genau wenn wir
windows auf sein was guck mal es ist jetzt noch schlechter mit dem mit der
treiber version geworden und und und den default settings also ganz ganz wird champ ist das
In die andere Richtung ist er tatsächlich ein bisschen besser
Doch ein Ukraine-Nass
Ne, von der Hardware ist das Minis-Forum einfach zu nice
Ganz ehrlich, das Minis-Forum hat einen PCI-Express-Slot
Zur Not baue ich da eine eigene 10-Gegner-Zweck-Karte ein und scheiß drauf
Das geht ja immer noch
Wieso variiert das?
Weil die Netzwerkkarte Schrott ist.
Nee, das ist nicht normal.
Guck mal.
Wenn ich zwischen meinem Desktop-Rechner und meinem jetzigen NAS das mache, ja?
Da läuft auch ein IPath drauf.
Dann...
Äh...
What?
Eben war es doch noch besser.
Kann das sein?
dass die ok ok leute wir müssen jetzt noch mal was machen es ist ja super weird
guck hier so jetzt ist gut dass sie was für keine ahnung was die netzwerk karte treibt
aber das ist okay so ist das eigentlich auch die ganze zeit immer
guck das ist immer relativ stabil so irgendwas um 9,2 9,3 9,4 so das knick im kabel das essen das
ist ein direct attached kupferkabel was sich auch nicht bewegt oder so wenn das
ein klick hätte dann wäre es halt komplett im arsch so wir testen jetzt
gerade noch mal was ich mache jetzt mal ein iperf von hier auf die jetzige
nasskiste das ist bis auf ein paar retries ist das in ordnung ja aber das
hält sie immer noch in grenzen also das ist das ist jetzt okay
ja also das jetzt gut ich check halt einfach nett was das ding für probleme hat ich raff's
net so was wir jetzt noch mal probieren ist wir nehmen jetzt wir nehmen jetzt der blacklist vom
kölner treiber raus ja das kölner modul da sind den hersteller treiber und dann
reboot ich und dann benutzen wir den treiber der im kölner drin ist das habe
ich glaube ich noch gar nicht probiert ob der vielleicht an meinem switch jetzt
besser ist wirklich ist es so und deswegen wir müssen das jetzt mal
systematisch machen wir müssen mal die die optionen durchprobieren treiber
version und wirklich mal ich muss mir das dann mal aufschreiben eine textdatei wie was wo wie
schnell an welchem switch ist weil ansonsten blicke ich dann immer durch in der tram fs
wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe nichts vergessen habe sollte nach dem reboot die kiste
wieder hochkommen und jetzt den treiber aus dem kölner verwenden also den offiziellen wie heißt
das mainline körner ansehen jemand standardmäßig hat für mann hat linux
größer die lukas kölner größer 615 verwendet
das macht er eigentlich drei stunden rum irgendwelche in die tram fs dinger zu
bauen okay so jetzt haben wir es hier mit dem offiziellen r169 oder sowas
hier da sieht man es doch sieht man nicht ich hoffe das ding kommt jetzt
hoch ich habe nicht irgendwas vergessen oder so
schauen wir mal das ist china chinesen netzwerk netzwerk treiber ja aber
angeblich sind die Realtek Windows-Treiber
viel besser. Ich habe einen Test
gesehen von einem auf Reddit.
Der hat zwei dieser Netzwerkkarten unter
Windows miteinander zusammengestöpselt
und die erreichen da konstant 9,6
Gig.
Damit wäre ich auch zufrieden, ja. Das wäre
top.
Aber das Ding will irgendwie nicht.
Ziemlich satt.
Okay, da sind wir wieder.
Schauen wir mal. ETH-Tool.
Gucken wir mal, was da für ein Treiber
Äh, Moment.
War das ein ETH-Tool minus I?
Äh, Treiber-Version.
Genau. Das ist jetzt der offizielle
Linux-Kernel-Treiber.
Iperf. Okay, machen wir
erstmal das Iperf gegen
die andere Netzwerkkarte.
Ha!
Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha!
Leute!
3 M-Bit.
Max, hast du mitbekommen, dass die Polizei
Admins aus dem Bett geklingelt hat?
Ja.
Habe ich.
Ich meine,
der Fuck, Alter.
Das ist eine 10-Gegner-Zweck-Karte.
Was ist denn mit denen kaputt, Alter?
So, jetzt machen wir es nochmal.
Reverse.
Bam.
Das ist nur in eine Richtung.
Reverse super stable.
9,4 Gigabit.
Bam.
Okay, Iperf minus S.
Machen wir es nochmal von hier.
Ähm...
So semi-gut.
Aber immerhin nicht ganz beschissen.
Oh, guck mal hier.
14,7, 19, 26, 27 Megabit.
Das ist halt nix.
Das ging über Klingeldraht früher schneller.
Wann war wieder ein Dual mit dem Kabu und dem Friseur?
Auf Terminal.
Warum?
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage.
Warum ausgerechnet auf Terminal?
Die Map war doch richtig ass, Alter.
Warum Terminal?
Warum nicht 1 vs. 1 auf Rust?
Intervention only
Aber warum
Terminal?
Chat, jetzt mal eine Frage
Lass mal überlegen, an welche
Maps aus MW2
kann man sich denn überhaupt noch erinnern?
Also
Terminal auf jeden Fall
Ähm
Skid Row
Gab's dann, die war eigentlich ganz gut, glaube ich
Scrapyard
Dann diese
diese Fabrik-Map.
Ich hab Quarry.
Quarry? Oder wie das heißt?
Ähm. Rust.
Favela.
Estate.
Jo, die war auch kacke.
Das war Terminal mit dem Flugzeug.
Ach, nee.
Die. Ach, ich weiß. Die Wüsten-Map.
Ja, wie. Die war auch nicht schlecht.
Die Wüsten-Map. Wie hießen die nochmal?
Äh.
Oh, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Sobald ich den Namen sehe, weiß ich sofort,
dass es die ist. Afghan. Okay, das war natürlich
naheliegend,
wenn die in Afghanistan ist.
Ja, ja, ja.
Highrise.
Warte mal.
Highrise. War Highrise nicht das Ding,
wo sie alle immer von dem
Kran getrickshottet haben?
Wie die Blöden?
Wo dann am Ende
der Runde sich gegenseitig geflasht
und gestunkranated wurde?
und um dann will zu spinnen und krasse trickshots zu machen
Das ist doch auch moment ist nicht auf high rise auch
Dieser legendäre clip hier entstanden
Es ist doch auch oder
das ist
Mami, get the camera!
Ja das hier, das ist doch, oder?
Highrise.
Aber ich muss sagen...
Also einer meiner Lieblings Clips ist ja immer noch das N64 Kit.
Das ist der beste, Alter.
Das ist der beste.
Der ist voll am durchdrehen.
Nintendo 64.
Der komplett am ausrasten.
64. Ja, siehste?
Über was? Chat.
Jetzt mal. Ihr seid ja noch ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Also in meinem Alter ist man bei
einem Nintendo 64
so ausgeflippt, wenn man den bekommen hat.
Bei was flippen die Leute denn heute so aus?
Was müsste man denn heute
Kindern in dem Alter schenken, dass die so ausflippen?
Fortnite-Skins?
Nee, da sind sie wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen jünger für.
Was?
Was ist da heute
in der Generation so angesagt?
Roblox.
Roblox-Dinger oder so.
6-7-Merch.
Was sind denn V-Bucks?
Oder wie?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Was soll das sein?
Ach, Fortnite. Das ist die Fortnite-Währung.
Ich hab's auch grad gegoogelt.
Siehste mal,
wie planlos ich bin, was das angeht.
Aber zurück zum
Nass.
Sind wir uns einig, Chat,
dass das hier ein absolut
indiskutabler Speed ist
für eine 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte?
Oder meint ihr, das ist
fein? Meint ihr, das ist fein?
Ich meine, der Trend geht ja zur Entschleunigung.
Vielleicht ist das ja einfach...
Gibt es nicht...
Habe ich auch letztens irgendwo gelesen.
Gibt es nicht aktuell diesen irgendwie Analog-Trend auf TikTok?
So nach dem Motto...
Vor allem auf TikTok ist halt gerade der Witz dabei.
So nach dem Motto, ey Leute, mein Leben analog, ohne Internet und Social Media ist viel geiler.
Ja, und, aber das posten die Leute dann auf TikTok.
Oder ist das auch schon zu Zoomer für euch und wisst ihr nicht Bescheid?
Wobei das ja nicht mal Zoomer, das ist Generation Alpha oder so.
Das ist zu Alpha, ja.
okay also deshalb ist halt mies was halt super merkwürdig ist guckt mal ich war
in der speed ist jetzt auch nicht gut aber er ist nicht super beschissen aber
der hier da fuck also man sieht ja dass das prinzipiell eigentlich eigentlich
ne kann das nicht am switch liegen das kann ich am kabel liegen das kann ich an
der netzwerkkarte das dass das das kann ich an meiner netzwerkkarte im desktop
liegen weil cook netzwerkkarte hier im desktop zu einem anderen 10 gig ding vollkommen fein ja in
beide richtungen vollkommen fein ich kann es eigentlich mir nur erklären das liegt an
dieser karte willi tech netzwerkkarte vielleicht vielleicht in verbindung mit meinem switch so was
mir jetzt ausprobieren chat was wir jetzt ausprobieren ist back report an will tech
schreiben. Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendeinen Erfolg
hätte.
Witzigerweise, wenn ich den Realtek-Treiber
benutze, dann ist, das kommt ja auch noch
dabei, wenn ich den Realtek-Treiber,
ich hab rebooted, ja,
wenn ich den offiziellen Realtek-Treiber
verwende,
dann ist der Speed deutlich besser,
aber auch
nicht top.
Der ist besser, aber auch
nicht zufriedenstellend.
So, was wir jetzt mal
ausprobieren, Leute. Ich schnapp
mir jetzt mal hier den sp plus auf rj 45 10 gig adapter von mikro tic also an dem switch sollten
so und ich stöpsel den mal in meinen switch im rack rein und dann steckt sich stecke ich das
nass daran an und dann treiber selbst vibecon wahrscheinlich wären wir erfolgreicher als bei
bei Realtek ein Bugreport aufmachen.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, man kann so einen Treiber nicht selbst programmieren, weil dir komplett die Hardware-Specs fehlen.
Letztendlich ist ja Treiber sehr viel Byte-Magic an irgendwelche Stellen im RAM schreiben und dann wissen, weil du der Hersteller bist, dass es geht.
das kannst du selbst eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht machen.
So, ich hab das jetzt über ein SFP Plus Modul dran.
Also, aber Chat, Chat, wir sind uns einig, es kann nicht am Kabel liegen,
weil es ist schneller mit anderen Netzwerktreibern
und der Speed zwischen den zwei Nasses ist ja teilweise auch okay.
Ja, also am Kabel kann es auf gar keinen Fall liegen.
Zum Glück, ja, zum Glück,
die sind deutlich besser unterstützt,
diese Aquantik-Dinger.
Also Kabel fällt raus.
Kabel fällt komplett raus.
Also das kann es nicht sein.
So, da sind wir wieder.
Iperf.
Gucken wir mal.
Wie es jetzt ist.
Äh, Moment, falsche Kiste.
So.
Es ist kein Unterschied. Es ist einfach Schrott.
Es ist kein Direct Attach Kabel.
Direct Attach ist nur zwischen meinem Desktop und dem Switch.
Das NAS selber hat nur einen RJ45 Stecker. Da ist kein Direct Attach Kabel.
Und dass meine Netzwerkkarte im Desktop richtig funktioniert,
über das Direct Attach siehst du ja hier so eine andere 10G Kiste mit einer gescheiten Netzwerkkarte drin,
überhaupt kein Problem.
Also es kann auch
nicht an der Netzwerkkarte im Desktop
oder an dem Direct Attach Kabel liegen.
Weil zur anderen Kiste
funzt ohne Probleme.
Also spricht alles für die schrottige
Netzwerkkarte
im
Nass.
Okay.
Also
ein Modul zu verwenden macht auch
keinen Unterschied.
Also ich habe jetzt hier ein SR4 Plus Modul auf RJ45, da angeschlossen auch keine Kunst, auch nicht.
Gehen wir nochmal hier von nass zu nass, das ist schön schnell in die Richtung und so rum ist wahrscheinlich Schrott.
Das kann es doch echt nett sein.
So, was wir jetzt noch machen können, wir können Energy Efficient Ethernet ausschalten.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren, weil das können wir machen ohne Reboot.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Vielleicht bringt das ja schon was.
Und jetzt als nächstes würde ich sagen...
Okay, Chat, wir können...
Was wollen wir machen als nächstes?
Es gibt mehrere Sachen, die wir ausprobieren müssen.
Nochmal die Hersteller-Dreiber-Version.
An einem anderen Switch.
und ins BIOS mal wirklich die PCI Express Energiesparfunktion ausschalten.
Was meint ihr, was am sinnvollsten ist, zuerst zu machen?
Kannst du zweite NIC mal testen, auch wenn es...
Ja, könnte ich theoretisch.
Nee, ich mach das einfach auf
Und bau ne 10 Gig ein
10 Gig Netzwerkkarte ein
Und teste es mit der
Aber da muss ich das Ding ja erst wieder auf den Tisch stellen
Oben
Hast du mal die MTU gecheckt?
Naja, es geht ja in eine Richtung schnell
Oder
Okay, das ist immer noch abwack langsam
Warte mal, ETH Tool
Wo sieht man denn
Die MTU
die eingestellt ist.
Hier nicht. Minus I?
Okay.
ETH-Tool. Check.
MTU. Oder kann man es
mit IPR zählen?
Hier.
1500. Also alles gut.
Ist die 5-Kick-Nick besser?
Weiß ich nicht. Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wie heißt dein Desktop-Environment? Das ist KDE.
Ganz normales KDE.
Guck hier.
Äh, Moment.
Settings.
Ganz normales KDE
stellt. Aber das
allerwichtigste ist
Wobbly Windows.
Also ich kann es nur empfehlen,
Leute.
Übrigens,
dass das so ruckelt,
das liegt nicht hier an mir,
das liegt an den 48 fps die das stream hat das kann das schöne weiche wobbeln
nicht richtig darstellen
warum ist er das aufgeräumt weil ich den desktop unter linux für nichts verwende
ich habe einfach alles im fullscreen erstes erster tab browser zweiter tab
terminal dritter tab normalerweise editor ide und dann halt hier entweder
der Backend, Frontend oder so.
Und hier habe ich Ceterino auf dem vierten.
Also, MTU ist es anet.
Okay.
Es könnte gut sein, dass es an
Energiesparoptionen liegt. Habe ich jetzt schon öfters bei
Realtek und Intel gehabt.
Das hatte ich auch, wenn ich
das im offiziellen Realtek-Treiber
ausschalte, die Energiesparfunktion,
dann ist es
etwas besser.
Wie heißt sie, Nick?
Das ist eine,
guck hier, ach so sieht man das überhaupt,
ja, das ist eine RTL
8127.
Die sind relativ neu, die gibt es erst seit
so eineinhalb Jahren oder sowas in dem Dreh.
Ja, nur dass das RTL hier für Real-Tag steht.
In welche Richtung es sich richtig geht?
In, Moment.
ausgehend
von der nasskiste raus
also quasi in sende richtung
super wird
book sie ist auch hier wenn ich von der anderen kippe von der anderen kiste aus
teste dann hat hier reverse
Dann hat er nur irgendwas mit 1916.
Irgendwas M-Bit.
Lohnt sich bei einem kommenden
Fiber-to-the-Home-Glasfaseranschluss
ein neuer Router
oder reicht ein externes Glasfasermodem?
Oh, ist schwer zu sagen.
Also ein externes Glasfasermodem wird an sich reichen.
Da kommt Glasfaser auf der einen Seite rein, er hat 45 Stecker auf der anderen Seite raus.
Wobei ich mich dann ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so gut auskenne, weil ich habe selbst keinen Fiber to the Home.
Die Geräte, die man da vom Hersteller bekommt, oder besser gesagt vom Hersteller, jetzt falsch, vom Provider bekommt, sind das denn wirklich reine Glasfasermodems, wo dann auf der anderen Seite noch irgendwas, was auch immer, machen muss?
Ähm, ja, das sind reine Glasfasermodems.
Das heißt, auf der anderen Seite brauchst du einen Router, der was macht?
PPPoE? Nee, oder?
Was muss denn der auf der anderen Seite dann machen?
PPP, äh, wirklich?
PPP-OE?
Ja gut, also wenn das, wenn das noch notwendig ist, und das kein Voll, alleine, ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir wahrscheinlich das Leben einfach machen, ähm, und mir ne Glasfaser Fritzbox kaufen.
nicht als main router aber fritz boxen sind super multifunktionsgeräte in der regel ich
kenne jetzt nicht ich hatte selbst noch keine glasfaser fritz box aber die dinger sind halt
top für web und für halt dsl modem oder kabel modem oder glasfasermodem endpunkt sind die dinger
gut die dinger taugen auch als alleiniger router ja also ist es nicht wenn du so nur die standard
sachen brauchst wie zum beispiel im geste was in gäste wlan wlan internes netz und und ein
matt ausgehen da ist eine fritz box vollkommen fein vollkommen ausreichendes multifunktionsgerät
wenn du intern im netz ja mehrere wlan haben willst oder irgendwie da noch für
die access points und hast dich dann fritz box aber die fritz box davor ja
als zusätzliches gerät ist ja eigentlich immer immer gut
sie war schön dass du da bist also ich würde mir wahrscheinlich auch eine
glasfaser fritzbox kaufen wenn ich wenn ich glasfaser kommen würde jetzt für
die firmware update es gibt neuen treiber kukier da es gibt
es gibt neuen treiber den hatte ich vorher auch installiert damit ist ein
bisschen besser also ich habe ja vorhin verglichen den
treiber von real tech wirst es den treiber der im linux kornel drin ist
dass das war so richtig schlecht ist der treiber der linux kornel drin ist der
offizielle Treiber aus der
vom Hersteller, der ist etwas
besser.
So, was wir jetzt machen.
Ich gehe jetzt mal ins BIOS
und im BIOS, guck mal, auch die
ganzen V-Tries und so, da ist irgendwas
richtig heftig im Arsch.
Im BIOS schalten
wir jetzt mal
ab die Stromsparfunktion.
Falls das geht, okay.
Da muss ich nur mal kurz meine
KVM-Kiste holen. Wo ist denn meine
KVM-Kiste? Hier hängt sie rum.
KVM-Stelz. Mal kurz
entwirren.
Vielen Dank.
So, da sind wir.
Rude.
Nicht, dass wir das bräuchten.
Ich wollte bloß gucken, ob alles funktioniert.
Okay, ähm...
Reboot.
Dann wollen wir mal ins BIOS.
Oder ins BIOS, wie es die geilen Leute sagen.
Und streng genommen ist es ja nicht mal ein BIOS,
sondern ein EFI.
UEFI.
No HDMI Signal detected.
No.
Da sind wir.
So, Setup.
Boah, Alter.
Warum ist das so laggy gerade?
Guck dich das mal an.
WTF?
Neuladen.
Okay.
Besser, aber immer noch nicht gut.
Nicer Input-Lag, ja.
Man könnte mal theoretisch die
KVM updaten.
Aber Klick ist witzigerweise schnell.
Leichter Leck.
Was für Linux läuft auf dem Last Android Truebox-Mods?
So.
Wo könnte man jetzt ACPI-Settings?
Nee.
Wo könnte man jetzt Stromsparfunktionen ein- und ausschalten?
Onboard-Device-Settings?
Nee.
Android durch Proxmox?
Proxmox ist da drauf.
Alter, die Mauszeiger!
Guckt euch das mal an!
Nee, ACPE-Settings war nix.
Ähm.
Was haben wir denn hier unten noch?
Äh.
amd pc express configuration cbs
irgendwo konnte man da irgendwie ich weiß auch genau irgendwo katholik das
cpu configuration configuration links configuration configuration configuration
network stack da ist es nicht guckt da ist nicht das weiß ich dass es da nicht
ist cpu configuration ich bin ich jetzt dumm wo ist es denn ich habe das doch schon mal gefunden
da ich weiß dass es das gibt ja ich hab das ich hab sogar schon mal gesehen
so viele so viele möglichkeiten gibt es doch nicht okay okay wir müssen das wir müssen jetzt
von oma cpu configuration ist es net on board device settings gibt es da irgendwas für
acp settings gibt es nichts hardware monitor gibt es nichts dafür netzwerk
der configuration gibt es nichts amd cbs cpu options okay gibt es aber auch nichts für pc
express mbo gfx configuration ist nix audio configuration ist nix rest an fch no smu no
ddr configuration pbs pc express configuration sag mal bin ich dumm ich weiß dass es die settings
gibt wir waren da sogar im stream schon drin nicht ziel state einstellung als
pm oder wieder kalt es gibt bin ich jetzt komplett hängen geblieben alter
ich weiß dass es die settings gibt 100 prozent ich chat ich gehe jetzt mal
pinkeln ich gehe jetzt ich gehe jetzt ich gehe jetzt pinkeln und danach sind
die settings da
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Excellent.
Okay.
Advanced.
Wo könnte das denn sein?
Das muss unter Onboard Device Settings sein.
Da ist es, Alter.
PCI-Port.
Okay, Okulink ist
disabled. Das ist ja in Ordnung.
ASPM-Mode Auto. Moment.
Ich will es ja nur für die Netzwerkkarte.
10 Gig.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist schon...
Das ist schon...
Das ist schon okay, dass das...
Ähm...
Dev2Funk2.
Also beschissener Benamen
hätte man es jetzt auch nicht mehr können, oder?
Disable mal alles?
Nee.
braucht es ja zu viel aber wir können das mal ausprobieren
ja aber was ist für ein schwachsinn links geht mir geht ja nicht der meint damit nicht
netzwerk link der meint damit wc express das lasse ich auf auto stehen
ist denn also ich meine es wäre ja von der idee her wenn es hier steht dass das
die netzwerk hat okay wir stellen den kaffee disabled ich stelle jetzt die allen asps mod
einfach auf das selbe okay als pm des abels ist abels so das abels es ist irgendwo an
disabled
es leckt hat ein bisschen disabled disabled okay so jetzt haben wir alles aus
Jetzt haben wir alles aus
Okay
Wenn es übrigens, Chat, wenn es da auch rumspackt
Hat das einen Nutzen?
Weiß ich noch nicht
Keine Ahnung, ob das was bringt
Ja, Power Top
Hab ich aber nicht
Persistet
So
Schildkröte.
Gibt es bei euch so viele Schildkröten in der Türkei?
So, also loggen wir uns mal ein und gucken uns das jetzt an.
Schauen wir mal, was der jetzt sagt.
So, ETH-Tool, bla, blub.
Das ist jetzt die Linux-Standard-Körnel-Version.
Was ist genau das Problem?
Meine Netzwerkkarte ist abfuck langsam.
So.
Bam.
Zack.
Okay, also das hat schon mal nichts gebracht.
Okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass das aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Probleme mit diesem Switch hat.
Was wir jetzt
machen ist...
Was wir jetzt machen ist...
Der Patch hilft überhaupt nichts.
Den kenne ich.
Der Patch ist zum Anzeigen von
irgendwelchen Geschwindigkeiten.
9 Gigabit klingt doch gut. Ja, Moment. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Du hast das davor nicht gesehen.
Guck mal.
In eine Richtung sind es 23 Mbit.
In die andere ist es okay.
Also das hier...
Wie würdest du das denn bezeichnen?
Also ich würde das als Abfuck langsam bezeichnen.
So.
Okay.
Wir stöpseln das Ding jetzt ab.
Ich brauche ein längeres Netzwerkkabel.
Ich kann das Ding jetzt ja nicht aus dem Rack ausbauen.
Wo habe ich denn...
Habe ich nicht irgendwo noch ein bisschen längeres Netzwerkkabel?
Also wir sind schon mal einig, am Netzwerkkabel kann es ja nicht liegen.
Okay.
Chat.
Ich stöpsel jetzt um.
Ich stöpsel jetzt nochmal an den anderen 10-Gig-Switch.
Nur mal um zu ausschließen, dass das irgendwelche Probleme mit dem Switch hat.
Das sind 145 Kabel.
So
Stöpsel das jetzt um
Ich hoffe das Kabel reicht
Es könnte knapp werden
Warte mal
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Und ansonsten muss ich noch
Ein längeres Netzwerkkabel suchen
Das Problem ist
Ich hab ein Netzwerkkabel
Ich hab ganz kurze
So 15 cm
Ich hab 1 m
Und ich hab
Ich glaub 15 m
Hab ich noch irgendwo
Hier 1
Aber rumliegen
Aber so was
Was ich jetzt bräuchte
So 3 m
Hab ich glaub ich gar keins
Warte mal
Ich gucke mal
Ich bleibe auch soweit.
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Ich muss doch irgendwo ein halbwegs gescheit langes Netzwerkkabel haben.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
wir können gleich noch was anderes buchen das ist eine gute idee aber ich hatte auf dem box
noch schon mal ganz neuen köln installiert ich glaube 619 als der neu war allerdings gebracht
aber es kommt das ist eine gute idee ist kann man ausbringen aber vorbrüchen netzwerk habe finden
Ich werde sterben.
Ich hab was, ich hab was.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Also.
Das bringt nichts, das bringt nichts.
das bringt nichts mit dem energy efficient internet das habe ich schon ausprobiert das
bringt nichts so also jetzt sind wir hier jetzt jetzt sind wir am mikro tics switch
schauen wir mal wie ob das da jetzt besser ist also wir sind immer noch auf der linux
Kernel-Netzwerk-Kartentreiber-Version.
Ja, also nicht vom Hersteller.
Warte mal, die Richtung ging
doch schnell die ganze Zeit, oder?
Oder nicht?
Doch, ich glaube, die ging die ganze Zeit schnell.
Haha, süß.
Ah.
Okay, also das kann es schon
immer nicht sein.
So.
Also der Treiber, der im Linux-Kernel
drin ist, der funzt
einfach nicht richtig.
Der macht nur Proletarien.
Also es kann...
Ich habe jetzt das Netzwerk Kabel getauscht.
Ich hatte schon an einem Aeon 45
Stecker direkt. Ich hatte schon
an einem SFP Plus zu Aeon 45.
Also es ist ja mehr oder weniger alles ausgeschlossen, was das sein kann.
So, Strom, Strom, Spar, Gedöns, kann es auch nicht sein.
So, jetzt probieren wir nochmal was anderes.
Wie sieht es denn jetzt zu der Kiste hier aus?
Auch Abfack, Alter, was ist das denn?
Okay, wir machen jetzt tatsächlich nochmal hier Energy Efficient aus.
hast du mal hast du mal
hast du mal ipad gemacht invisible also bei mir das hat es richtig große probleme
es kann keine fake nicht sein es ist die onboard netzwerkkarte da müsste der hersteller gefakt
haben.
Ja, das ist okay.
Da wäre ich voll
fein mit, ja.
Also, das ist
sehr merkwürdig.
Das kann's
doch nicht sein.
Okay, ich hab
noch eine Idee. Eins probieren wir noch aus
Ich mach mal wirklich Power Off.
Und dann schalte ich nochmal ein.
Ist doch alles disabled.
Ähm, dann stelle ich das...
Ich habe nämlich gelesen, das Ding hat manchmal Probleme beim Reboot.
So, und dann probieren wir jetzt nochmal die Herstellertreiber.
Weil mit denen ist es besser.
Also da weiß ich, dass es besser ist.
So.
Jetzt die Kiste aus, muss ich mal aufstecken
So
Ja, den habe ich auch ausgeschaltet
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Ob das daran liegt
Invisible, hast du mal bei dir
geguckt, wie viel
Stromverbrauch das Ding hat
bei dir.
Also ich bin eigentlich ganz
angetan von der Hardware. Ich finde,
das ist echt eine gute Kombination. Wenn die
Netzwerkkarte nicht so rumspacken würde.
Wenn es ein iPerf-Bug ist,
kann auch kein iPerf-Bug sein,
weil
mit dem
Herstellernetzwerk-Treiber ist es ja schneller.
Das liegt eindeutig...
Also für mich ist das eindeutig eine Netzwerkkarte, die rumspackt.
So, da sind wir wieder.
Iperf, gucken wir jetzt mal.
Okay, andere...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Äh.
Was?
Warum?
Leute, das Ausschalten hat was gebracht.
What?
Nicht Reboot, Power Off und wieder von Hand einschalten.
Moment.
Ja, ja, alles gut.
Was ein Schrott, Alter
So richtig zufrieden bin ich damit auch nicht
Ich hätte gerne 9,4
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist ja schon okay
So, ein Problem
Was ich hatte mit dem
Mit dem eingebauten Netzwerk-Treiber, also mit dem, mit dem, ähm, im Linux-Körnel.
Das ist auf jeden Fall was mit dem Treiber, ja.
Ähm, Problem, was ich hatte, ist, dass das in der VM relativ langsam war.
Das können wir jetzt nochmal ausprobieren.
Wir, wir starten jetzt mal.
Wir starten jetzt mal die Open Media Vault VM.
Und machen da mal einen IPerf drinnen.
Das ist Debian, ja.
Directory Mapping Invalid Path.
Schuckt.
Wie?
Das non-exists. Warum nicht?
Also, ähm, Mount, Minus, ZFS, Mount.
Bin ich jetzt hängen geblieben?
Z, Pool, Import.
Hä, warum wurden denn nicht standardmäßig importiert?
Okay, whatever.
Start.
Geht's jetzt?
Okay, jetzt geht's.
Aber das kann's ja echt nicht sein, ne?
Dass man Power-Off machen muss,
dass das Kram wieder richtig funktioniert.
So.
52 war das 52 auch keine ahnung was haben wir denn hier ist 52 jahre den db an ist es glaube
ich oder db oder gut ich weiß gar was braucht was hatte ich dafür ein passwort für mein open
Media Wall. Okay, das ist das Richtige. Alles klar.
Sehr gut.
So, IPerf.
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache.
Wenigstens das
müsste ja schnell sein, weil das mit der
Netzwerkkarte gar nichts zu tun hat. Das geht nur
über die interne Bridge.
So, wir machen jetzt mal ein IPerf
on der VM
auf den Host.
Okay.
Das ist schnell. Das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, wenn ich
60 Gigabit
Easy
Okay, da wissen wir schon mal
Das macht dann weniger Probleme
Gut, das ist in Ordnung
Das ist okay, damit komme ich klar
So geil ist es auch nicht
Aber es ist in Ordnung
Okay
Also dann
iPerf
Mal hier auf der Kiste
Auf dem Nass
So, und jetzt gehen wir auf 52
Guckt
Das ist das Problem von dem Treiber, der im Kernel drin ist.
Der backt total rum mit VMs.
Der offizielle Hersteller-Treiber ist tatsächlich deutlich besser.
Der erreicht exakt die Hälfte.
In eine Richtung nur.
In die andere ist übrigens vollkommen fein und okay.
deswegen würde ich sagen,
Chat,
wir wissen jetzt ja,
woran das lag mit dem, dass es nur ein
Mbit hat und sowas.
Wir installieren
jetzt
den Herstellertreiber nochmal.
Hier.
Install.
Das da.
Und dann blacklisten wir den
Kerneltreiber. Und jetzt gucken wir uns das Ganze nochmal an.
Jetzt habe ich ja alle Stromsparfunktionen und sowas ausgeschaltet.
Ah, noch was anderes.
Wir können noch ein Update vom Switch machen.
Da muss ich mal kurz nachgucken, was der Switch für eine IP hat.
Wie hieß dieses Ding von MikroTik? Winbox, ne?
Das gibt es doch angeblich jetzt auch für Linux.
Mikrotik, Mikrotik Winbox für Linux. Gibt es das jetzt auch?
Was will es von mir?
abbrechen
so und jetzt muss man das blacklisten den treiber im kernel in tramfs neu bauen winbox
für linux gibt es doch jetzt auch
linux auf 401 und das gibt es auch ja okay alles gut
das ist das konfigurations für mikro tick router die dinge haben auch ein web interface mein
Mein Problem ist, ich weiß die IP gerade nicht.
Vor dem Router.
Und das Passwort nicht mehr.
Ich habe das Ding eingestöpselt und Hände hoch.
Nie wieder was mitgemacht.
Das ist der Router am Basteltisch.
Ich dachte mir, wenn wir da jetzt an dem gerade was testen,
dann sollten wir vielleicht den auch mal updaten.
Chat habe ich wieder.
Ist das ein Bug?
Das ist ein Bug?
Guckt mal.
Ich hab das...
Der hat wieder einen Tilde-Ordner angelegt.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt okay und er löscht nicht mein Heimatverzeichnis.
Okay, ja, alles in Ordnung.
Scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Okay, ähm...
Winbox.
Der sollte jetzt eigentlich die Routers
discoveren.
Hab ich gehofft.
Macht er aber nicht mehr, oder?
Früher ging das mal.
Früher ging das.
Da konnte der Router discoveren.
Das ist aber dumm.
Dass es nicht mehr geht.
Vielleicht hier unten?
Okay
Das ist aber echt hängen geblieben
Dass das nicht mehr funktioniert
Der müsste
Zwei Router finden
Oder zwei Mikrotikgeräte finden eigentlich
Das hat er früher auch
Mit der alten Winbox Version
Keine Ahnung warum der das jetzt nochmal findet
muss da ich gehen naja gut settings
was das
habe ich zwei fenster
also er findet nichts dann muss ich mal kurz hier gucken
in meinen DHCP.
Was der für eine IP hat.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass mir das Passwort noch einfällt,
weil ich damals vergeben habe.
Mikrotik.
Der da könnte es doch sein, oder?
Angeblich,
angeblich ist es
192 1682 punkt 137 oder auch nicht
oder auch nicht
Wie sieht es denn damit aus?
Der hier.
Was ist denn das nochmal für ein Router?
Was steht denn da drauf?
C-S-S-6108G.
Ah, das ist ein Switch.
Okay, dann ist das der hier.
Der da.
Oh, fuck. Keine Ahnung.
Ey, was weiß ich denn, was ich da vergeben hab?
Äh, SwitchOS, Default, User, Root.
Admin, Username, Admin.
Admin, Admin? Ah, okay.
Admin, Passwort, leer, auch gut.
Okay, Passwort, Passwort, bla, blub.
Ähm, das ist SwitchOS, das ist ja ganz abartig.
So.
Dann updaten wir das Ding auch gerade mal.
Upgrade.
What's new?
Latest available version.
Was für eine Version habe ich?
Sieht man das hier irgendwie?
Current install version.
2021.
Okay, da hat sich ein bisschen was getan.
download and upgrade
please do not interrupt
ok
ich mach nix
ok der switch rebootet sich gerade
oh das
alter wie schnell war denn das
firmware upgrade
das war ja das unproblematischste
schnellste firmware update was ich je gesehen hab
Das ging einfach instant. Blazingly fast.
Firmware-Update.
So, jetzt können wir nochmal Ei perfen mit dem alten Treiber.
Okay, also wie gehabt.
Also der Switch-Update hat sich jetzt nicht wirklich...
Hat sich jetzt nicht so gebracht.
Gut.
Dann machen wir das mal wieder zu.
Zack.
Und jetzt rebooten wir das mal.
Ich mach den mal aus.
Es buggt manchmal, wenn ich auf der Kommandozeile reboote.
weil das eigentlich funktionieren sollte seitdem ich die die kuh emotools ab so
also ich habe jetzt geplastet ich habe in den drama fs generated ja das heißt
wir sollten jetzt geboten ab search genau ich hab den okay ich habe jetzt
den neuesten Treiber installiert vom Hersteller,
den es gibt. Also, Reboot.
Wobei, Chat, ich hätte nicht
rebooten sollen, ne?
Ich hätte Power-Off machen sollen.
Power-Off, Power-On.
Wer weiß, was das Ding
für Schmerzen hat. Also, irgendwas backt da
richtig rum.
Ja, guck mal mal, wie schnell
als es nach dem reboot zumindest sollte der jetzt schon mal von haus aus mit media wall schneller
sein ich alias das bestimmt nicht weil sie früher gern auf servern installiert habe ich
hab so ein tool das nannte sich molly garth genau das hat reboot und sowas gesündigt so dass du
immer erst den servernamen eingeben muss das vor der reboot kannst hatte ich wohl auf allen
kisten drauf also weil selber drauf fand ich sehr praktisch und irgendwann habe ich dann einfach von
heute auf morgen aufgehört das zu installieren ipad guck mal okay in ordnung auch in ordnung
Jump zwar ein bisschen wild rum,
aber meinetwegen.
Import.
Ne, ne, ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kann hier mal ein iPad
Server starten.
Gucken, wie schnell er jetzt ist.
Also.
Okay.
Naja.
Ich mein,
warum der so jumpt, versteht
man auch nicht so richtig,
ehrlich gesagt, aber...
Ne?
Versteht man ehrlich gesagt nicht,
was er
da für Schmerzen hat, warum der so jumpt.
Macht das nicht wirklich Sinn?
Aber immerhin.
So, jetzt werden wir das wieder an den eigentlichen Switch stecken, weil es bringt mir ja nichts, wenn ich den am Switch hängen habe hier mitten im Raum. Ich will den ja im Rack haben.
so gar kein fix das ist ein switch us kiste gewesen und ich habe es über das
webinterface geupdatet so ich stöpsel das jetzt mal wieder einen richtigen switch dran
So, jetzt ist er an meinem Edge-Switch dran.
Mit direkt RJ45-Kabels.
Okay.
Nass, was ist dein Problem?
Oh Mann, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
...
Hä? Moment.
Als ich das Kabel rausgezogen hab,
ging's kurz oder was?
Ah ne, okay, da ist er wieder.
Whatever. Keine Ahnung, das muss man nicht verstehen.
Okay, IPerf.
Mal gucken,
ob das jetzt einen Unterschied gemacht hat.
Das ist immer noch okay. Das ist immer noch gut.
So richtig geil ist der Speed ja nicht. Ich meine besser als...
mein gott diese netzwerkkarte ist so scheiße alter
ok nächster test nächster test sp plus modul das okay jetzt jetzt haben wir wenigstens was
was man was ausprobieren können moment
ok jetzt ist es wieder am mikro tics switch jetzt ist wieder mikro tics
schnell okay die netzwerkkarte hat auf jeden fall probleme mit meinem switch anscheinend
also im linux kölner gibt es commits zu echt ja wirklich das letzte mal haben wir
den nämlich auch ausgecheckt und nichts gefunden zu sein wann wann denn moment moment moment
moment wird clown linux ich gucke auch noch mal nach weil das letzte mal haben wir da
geschaut da gab es noch nichts
was gibt's davon wann sind die
21 ok bleeding bleeding patches hier da müssen wir noch eine kölner version
warten anscheinend.
New Hardware Support. Ne, den kenn ich schon.
Der bringt nix.
Handled Applicate.
Okay, was auch immer.
Vielleicht bringt das was.
Vielleicht.
Update Hardware Configurations.
Das sind neue
Netzwerkkarten-Versionen.
Ah, das ist eine neue Netzwerkkartenversion.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, Magic.
Obviously, alles klar.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte.
Die Treiber bestehen zum größten Teil aus irgendwelche
Pake-Byte-XY
an diese Stelle.
Das kannst du nicht selbst machen.
Ja, ich meine,
vielleicht haben wir Glück
und das hier fixt irgendwas.
Das fixt irgendwas und mit einer der neueren Proxmox Versionen ist es dann viel besser.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann übrigens das Linux Kernel Update, das Linux auschecken sparen.
Okay.
Also.
Am MikroTik Switch hatten wir es jetzt ausprobiert ist es schnell.
Okay nächster Test.
Ich stöpsel es an meinen Switch mit dem gleichen SFP Plus Modul wie es jetzt am Mikrotik Switch
ist.
Nächster.
So, so, so
Mal gucken
Also immer wieder
Jetzt, jetzt ist es auch schnell
Okay
Okay, also
Interesting
Das heißt im Endeffekt
Der hat irgendwelche Probleme
Wenn er direkt per AJ45
An meinen Switch gestöpselt wird
Weird Champ, oder?
Sehr, sehr weird Champ
Ich meine, die Geschwindigkeit ist jetzt nicht super geil.
Aber, naja, damit kann ich leben.
Oder?
Chat, was meint ihr?
Also, wir haben hier irgendwie 8,8 in die Richtung und 9,1 in die andere Richtung.
Also, das ist okay.
Ja, aber an dem gleichen Switch, da liegt es aber am Switch.
Das liegt nicht am Switch.
Das liegt immer noch an der Zwergkarte.
Weil ich habe ja am gleichen Switch direkt am Port nebendran das alte NAS.
Und das hat überhaupt kein Problem.
Mehr schafft er bei dir auch nicht.
Okay.
Also das ist irgendein Zusammenspiel-Switch.
So, gut.
Dann gehen wir jetzt ins BIOS wieder und schalten die Stromsparfunktion ein.
Reboot.
Nicht reboot.
Leute, danach, erinnert mich mal dran,
ich muss unbedingt
Äh, alles klar.
Ich muss unbedingt nochmal
komplett ausschalten.
Komplett ausschalten, Power off, Power on
machen.
Alter, äh.
Wo war das jetzt?
advanced cpu kunden onboard device settings pc express port ok auto auto
auto
Das kann ausbleiben.
Auto.
Und.
Reboot.
Hardpower off oder Shuttle.
Also Power off auf der Kommandozeile meine ich.
Nicht Hardpower.
Also nicht ausschalten.
Ähm.
ich müsste den Switch mal firmware updaten.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch besser, könnte ich mir
vorstellen. Das Ding ist ja
uralt. Ja.
Und ich hab das seit, was weiß ich,
fünf Jahren oder so nicht mal firmware updatet.
Aber es ist okay.
Ganz ehrlich, ich komm damit klar.
Dann stöpsel ich das halt über das Modul dran.
Das ist ja auch okay.
Damit kann ich auch leben.
Okay.
äh Chat
warum genau ist
die Kiste jetzt nicht verfügbar
außer dass ich Stromsparfunktion
wieder eingeschaltet hab
mein Gott diese Netzwerkkarte
alter wie mich das abfuckt
ok gehen wir mal hier gucken
IP Add
der hat die Netzwerkkarte nicht erkannt
geil
GG
Äh, ifconfig
IP
Link
Okay, der hat die Netzwerkkarte
Jetzt gar nicht mehr erkannt
Das ist natürlich auch geil
Äh, mehr Pixel
Dann machen wir jetzt Power Off
Und ich schalte den nochmal ein und ich wette, dann erkennt er die wieder
Ey, das ist ja so reudig, Alter
Dieses Ding
Okay, so, ich stehe kurz auf
Und
So, ich entknoten nochmal kurz mein Headset
Wartet mal
Also, Invisible, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
haben wir jetzt ungefähr die gleichen
Performance-Werte.
Also, du hast auch ungefähr
9 Gig in beide Richtungen.
Probier mal Open FreeBSD.
Das bringt's mir jetzt auch nicht.
Aber was wir noch machen können,
Chat. Also was wir jetzt gleich noch machen,
wir booten nochmal.
Wir booten gleich mal.
Was sollen wir denn booten?
Welche Distributionen hatten die top
aktuellsten Sachen in einem Live-System?
Arch, by the way.
Ein aktuelles Cachy oder so.
Keine Ahnung. Irgendwas, wo das Neueste
vom Neuesten drin ist.
Immer noch nicht?
Alter, warum erkennt denn der die...
Will er mich jetzt verarschen?
Warum erkennt denn der jetzt die Netzwerkkarte gar nicht mehr?
WTF?
Der...
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Wie...
Kann mir das jetzt mal einer sinnvoll erklären?
Hast du sie nicht ge...
Ja, ich hab die...
Moment, Moment.
Ich hab die geblacklistet. Das ist aber auch richtig.
Warte mal.
Bin ich...
Okay, das ist richtig.
Ja.
Das ist okay. Ich hab die geblacklistet.
So soll es ja auch sein.
Ey, warum erkennt denn der jetzt die Netzwerke?
What the fuck, Alter?
Warum erkennt er die Netzwerkhard jetzt nicht mehr?
Das muss mir...
Das muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären.
Okay, Modprobe.
R8127.
Hä?
Ah.
Äh.
What the f...
Ich blick nicht mehr durch, äh.
IP-Link-Show.
Okay, das ist es auf jeden Fall schon mal, nicht?
Aber welche Biosettings, das verstehe ich nicht.
Blacklist, ne?
Ja, es wird der im Kernel enthaltene Treiber nicht geladen, aber ich habe hier ein extra Hersteller-Kernel-Modul.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen...
Ja, ja, geladen ist er wohl, ja.
Also jetzt blicke ich...
Ich meine, ich habe ja nichts geändert.
Ich hab den ja nicht...
Ich hab ja nix geändert. Ich hab nur im BIOS wieder
Stromsparfunktionen eingeschaltet.
Hab ich aus Versehen irgendwie was eingeschaltet,
was ich nicht hätte einschalten sollen?
Da müssen wir
nochmal ins BIOS. Ich glaube, vielleicht
hab ich irgendwas eingeschaltet, was ich nicht hätte einschalten sollen.
Ey, wir probieren mal was aus.
Äh, Mod...
Modprobe R
8129. Ne, ey.
8, 1 und 6.
Ne, 8169.
ok die netzwerk nein da fehlt nichts das hat er eben auch funktioniert das kann
das liegt nicht an ein bio settings dadurch da also wenn ich den offiziellen offizielle
modul lade juckt den auch nicht dann habe ich irgendwas verstellt jetzt im bios gerade
irgendwas habe ich da verkackt die reboot monomans bios gucken aber was konnte ich
denn das eben großartig verkehrt machen
er kennt er die netzwerkkarte erst gar nicht guck mal irgendein mist werde ich
wohl gemacht haben hallo hallo lies was mich tippen
Also irgendwie hat gerade nichts Bock zu funktionieren, oder?
Hallo?
Ist der jetzt komplett im Arsch, oder was?
Okay, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt wirklich mal Hartstrom-Ausstrom anmachen.
Okay.
Dark Star.
Es ist doch vollkommen egal.
Das hat doch alles funktioniert.
Und dann habe ich im Bios Zeug rumgestellt.
Also es kann nicht am Linux liegen.
Checkt das jetzt oder was?
Oh, jetzt war ich zu lahm.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Geht es jetzt einfach wieder?
Es wäre auch zu einfach, wenn es jetzt einfach funktionieren würde.
Was ist das für ein Schrott, Mann?
Was habe ich denn im Bios jetzt da für ein Mist eingestellt?
Dass es nicht funktioniert.
Die Fehlermeldung im Linux-Kernel
war einmal und danach ging es.
Das ist es nicht.
Will ich jetzt ins BIOS?
Please, BIOS, BIOS.
Okay, da sind wir.
Was ein Gelege.
Oh, guck mal.
Jetzt geht es ja sogar halbwegs.
So, Advanced.
Onboard PC.
PC. So, was, was hab ich denn jetzt,
wo hab ich jetzt, wo hab ich denn jetzt verkackt,
Leute?
Ich hab kein Videos-Update
gemacht, ne. Wo hab ich denn jetzt verkackt,
hier?
Eigentlich nirgendswo, oder?
Chat,
ist doch alles gut.
Okay, machen wir nochmal.
jetzt machen wir das nochmal disabled alles.
Mein Gott, ist das ein
Gebrüllscheiß, ey.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir stellen das Ding jetzt mal explizit
auf enabled einfach nur für den fall der fälle ja falls es irgendwie mit auto rumspackt
Ich hab da draufgeklickt deswegen.
sieht so aus als würde gerade mit any desk ja der indische microsoft gold
support richtet gerade mein nass ein holt on holt on
Please, Netzwerkkarte, geh jetzt einfach wieder.
Oh.
Och, Mann.
Alter, ist die Netzwerkkarte jetzt im Arsch irgendwie, oder was?
WTF was ist das?
Okay ich nehme die Blacklist jetzt wieder raus.
Dann sollte er... Moment das ist eigentlich egal ich kann auch Modprobe A8169 machen.
Aber der findet das nicht, der findet Netzwerkkarte nicht.
Ok, ich remove den Kack jetzt einfach wieder.
So, dann machen wir das hier raus.
Genitram FS neu bauen.
So, jetzt haben wir alles wieder rückgängig gemacht.
Und der Kernel sollte jetzt...
Ich meine, das hätte auch so funktionieren müssen, aber...
Gucken wir mal.
Wir hoffen mal, dass die Netzwerkkarte jetzt wieder hochkommt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum er das überhaupt nicht mag, aber gut, man.
Hauptsache, meine Netzwerkkarte geht gleich wieder.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Aber sagt mal, Leute, es ist doch nicht normal, Alter.
Was ist das für komisches Gefrickel?
Christian Anfälle.
Okay.
Reboot.
Prage.
Chat, please.
Emote in Chat.
Wir müssen Prage machen, dass die Netzwerkkarte wieder geht.
Ich tippe mal selbst mit.
Prage.
Massive Prage.
Okay.
Jetzt kann es gar nicht anders als einfach funktionieren
Ansonsten mache ich ein BIOS
Ansonsten mache ich ein BIOS Reset
Wenn es jetzt nicht mehr geht
Okay, komm, wir pingen schon mal
Äh, pingen
Ja, was ist das denn?
Warum erkennt er die Netzwerkkarte nicht mehr?
Ich dreh durch
WTF
Was ist das
Was hat das Ding
Was hat das gemacht
Ist die jetzt explodiert oder was
Kann man das hier vielleicht ein bisschen vergrößern oder so
Ah nicht wirklich
Nicht wirklich gut
Da kann man es vergrößern
du hast ja auch von zehn sekunden vom strom gute idee gute idee gute idee
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Oh, shit.
No, ich kann keinen Pipe machen hier drinnen.
Nein.
Chat.
Der frisst alt, GR.
Ja.
Okay, 0 W Punkt.
So, okay.
Dann machen wir es so.
äh
Realtek?
Das ist was anderes.
Sonst findet er nix.
Der findet... Moment, der findet die...
Hä?
Der findet die Netzwerkkarte gar nicht mehr.
Die ist weg.
Die gibt's nicht mehr.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Jetzt machen wir die Hardcore-Variante.
Echo.
Ist das B? Moment.
Äh.
Brock.
Sus.
RQ-Trigger.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es B war.
Was kann man da reinpipen?
ist power of o
ich will hartes power aufmachen hartes power of ging das ja mit bs reboot dachte es gibt
Power-Off.
Okay, oh.
Oh ist es, was wir wollen.
Oh.
Bam.
Oh ne, jetzt fährt er nochmal runter.
Na gut, was auch immer.
Gut, ähm, ich werde jetzt mal
wirklich Strom aus,
Strom, Strom, Dings, und danach
resetten wir zur Not das BIOS, meinetwegen.
Was ein Scheiß, Alter.
Ich dreh durch.
Das war's für heute.
So.
Da sind wir wieder.
Jetzt bin ich...
Ah, guck mal, guck mal.
Er hat sie erkannt.
Da ist sie.
Leute, hier ist sie.
Guck mal.
Seht ihr es?
Monka WXD HD.
Krasser Scheiße.
jetzt ist jetzt guck jetzt ist es auch wieder da ist wieder okay okay dann
wissen wir jetzt dann wissen was wir machen müssen
also wir blacklisten das wir installieren wieder das modul als kernel
modul
Wir rebooten, gehen ins BIOS, schalten die ganzen Stromspargeschichten wieder ein.
Dann machen wir ein hartes Power-off.
10 Sekunden und wieder einschalten.
Oh, was ein Kram, Alter, was ein Kram, Mann.
Null.
Gut.
reboot in den tram fs erst neu generieren
das klingt richtig nach panes chamber jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind nachdem jetzt so einen
harten so einen harten reboot gemacht haben wenn er wenn er fertig in den tram fs generiert hat
mache ich aber kurz ein ipad mal gucken was er jetzt hat ob er jetzt aus irgendwelchen
welchen Kunden schneller, langsamer, genauso schnell ist.
Auf InitRAMFS
Generator, Generator mal
InitRAMFS.
Sorry, Chat, falls ich irgendwas
gesehen habe im Chat hier.
Ich konnte jetzt gerade nicht so richtig gucken.
Ja, also, äh, Invisible, bist du noch da? Hast du mal was virtualisiert drauf auf der Proxmox-Kiste? Also, richtige VM? Ich hab da, ich hab mit dem Standard-Linux-Kernel-Treiber da richtige Probleme, weil ich nur halb so, hast du ja gesehen, halb so viel Speed kriege in der VM. Nur 4,5 oder 4,7 Gig.
Okay
Also machen wir Iperf
Iperf
Dagegen
Okay, alles schnell, alles gut
Boah, wie das flutscht, hä?
Gegen das andere Nass
Gegen das andere Nass ist das richtig
Pog
Ah, und da schwankt es halt ein bisschen
Aber das ist okay
So, Iperf minus S
Hier nochmal rüber
Machen wir das hier nochmal
Ja.
Trotzdem sehr zackig, ne?
So kannst du den ja beschweren.
Sag mal, Chat, wisst ihr, was merkwürdig ist?
Wisst ihr, was echt merkwürdig ist?
Dass das jetzt viel nach dem Reboot, ne?
Dass das jetzt viel stabiler auf einmal ist.
Seht ihr das?
vorher hat es vorher hat das wild rum geschwenkt und jetzt ist er ziemlich
stable 9,4 9,47 9,46 muss man das in irgendeiner art und weise verstehen
irgendwie
okay oder auch nicht mach mal ipf ja also wie gesagt in der vm ist nur in der
vor allem auf dem haus ist schnell gut okay dann bevor ich jetzt wie starte
bevor ich jetzt wie starte ich mache jetzt noch mal ich starte
sommer die open media volt vor allem und verifiziere dass das auch immer noch
immer noch lahm ist vielleicht ist ja vielleicht ist ja der trick einfach
immer total strom aus strom rein zu machen für zehn sekunden und dann geht
alles wieder.
Möchtest du nicht starten?
Okay.
5-2.
Iperf.
Gucken wir mal hier drüber.
1-4-8.
Ja, guck, seht ihr?
Okay, das ist immer noch so.
Dass ich in der VM nur halbe Speed bekomme.
Was richtig nice wäre, wenn die Netzwerkkarte SAIOV unterstützen würde, dann bräuchte man gar nicht mehr über die Bridge gehen, sondern könnte quasi die Netzwerkkarte virtualisieren.
Oder nicht virtualisieren, halt so tun, als ob es ein eigenes Gerät wäre. Durchreichen.
Okay, das ist immer noch so. Na gut.
Power off.
Okay, was wollte ich jetzt machen? Ich wollte rebooten, ins BIOS gehen.
Im BIOS, warte mal, Chat, Chat, Chat.
hatte ich jetzt im bios die stromsparfunktion an oder aus ich habe
die wieder ausgeschaltet ok dann müssen wir jetzt rebooten ins bios
stromsparfunktion einschalten und dann rebooten und hart power off machen
Hallo?
Hallo? Hallo?
KVM!
Wie sie nicht reagiert hat.
Kann man vielleicht, wenn ich hier auf Settings gehe,
was haben wir denn? WebRTC? Direct?
Vielleicht ist es dann schneller?
Ui!
Guck mal!
Das ist schneller als WebRTC.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Was ist, wenn ich ihm jetzt sage, ich will...
Customize?
Okay, nee, macht keinen Sinn.
60 Hertz. Ich dachte, man könnte vielleicht 120 Hertz oder so machen.
Okay, dann ist das anscheinend...
Okay, dann bist du vom gleichen...
backen sagen wir mal betroffen den der linux kölner wohl in dieser version mit dem treiber
gerade hat.
What the...
Alter!
Please!
Oh shit.
Mein Browser crasht gerade.
Oh!
Ach, ich hab Scheiß drauf.
Also, Advanced.
Onboard. PC Express.
So.
Okulink kann disabled bleiben.
Auto.
guckt mal mit chat guckt mal bitte mit dass ich jetzt nix als an klick so ich
mache nur aspm wieder an das ist alles was ich vor hab aspm wieder ein mein gott
Ey, BIOS, stell es mal ordentlich hier.
Was ist das für ein Geläge, Alter?
Moment.
Chat, wartet mal.
Ich mache jetzt mal ein Chrome auf, okay?
Habe ich ein Chrome installiert?
Vielleicht.
Wie heißt das mit dem Nick-Virtualisieren?
S-R-I-O-V.
Äh, Chromium muss ich da installieren.
Ne, SAIOV, dann kannst du in die Netzwerkkarte mehrfach PCI-Paths throughen.
Das ist richtig nice.
Och nee.
Muss ich erst noch ein Systemupdate machen.
Arch, by the way.
Okay.
auto auto 5 bleibt es ebelt auto auto und letzte so jetzt werde ich rebooten und die
netzwerkkarte wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gehen dann mache ich jetzt hart schalte ich
die linus kiste wieder aus wartet stärker raus auch gleich zehn sekunden warten wieder rein
hast du ja das ist keine schöne wortkreation es guckt mal es versteht jeder was gemeint ist
das ist doch das wichtigste chat versteht ihr wenn ich sage du kannst mit srv eine
Netzwerkkarte mehrfach PCI passtruhen. Versteht man was ich was ich sagen will?
Nodders, ne?
Okay, ich habe jetzt nichts von der Netzwerkkarte gesehen.
Ist grad voll am abkacken gerade.
Ist denn jetzt
Ach jetzt geht die Netzwerkkarte
Das war wohl nur mal zufällig jetzt
Dass es nicht ging
Das war nur Zufall
Dass es sich ausge
Okay was auch immer
Äh
Okay wir haben den richtigen Treiber
Alles gut
So Iperf
Dahin
Ah ja
immerhin, immerhin, ja.
Schwankt ein bisschen, aber immerhin.
Minus R.
Okay, gut. Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Warum auch...
Warum auch immer
das Meer schwankt damit?
Das verstehe ich nicht wirklich.
Aber das ist in Ordnung.
Okay, Iperf minus S.
So.
Jetzt ist er noch langsamer.
Ey, diese Netzwerkkarte, das ist so ein Schrottding.
Ja, und das geht ja noch.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen
Okay, das könnte jetzt aber wiederum an...
The fuck?
Was ist das?
Das könnte jetzt an Stromsparfunktionen tatsächlich liegen.
Da kriege ich ja Anfälle bei.
Arch installieren, Linux Mainline testen
Ich hatte da schon mal
Ähm, hast recht
Ne, es ist anscheinend off, oder?
Ich hatte schon mal 619er Kernel drauf
Hä? Lag das jetzt doch an EEE?
Ne, 7.0 RC5 habe ich noch nicht drauf gehabt.
Hä? Warum schwankt das jedes Mal?
Ey, das ist so ein Shit, Mann.
Okay, machen wir das mal on.
Gucken, was dann passiert.
ok so also ein ich muss wieder starten
im prinzip das gleiche
Moment, iPath ist gecrasht?
Hab ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Chat, habt ihr jemals iPath crashen sehen?
Haha.
Okay, damit kann ich, ey, weißt du was?
Scheiß drauf.
damit kann ich leben, komm, ist doch egal.
Was wir jetzt aber nochmal
machen ist, Echo
wartet mal, Echo O nach
Prog Suisse AccuTool.
Ich mache jetzt nochmal richtig harten Power
auf.
Und dann gucken wir nochmal, was Sache ist.
Bam!
Strom raus, Strom rein. Gleich wieder am Start.
10 Sekunden warten.
Startet wieder.
Hinken wir mal, dass wir gucken
Wobei wir können auch einfach hier gucken
Auf der KVM
Ob der jetzt ordentlich startet
Chat, ich hab den Eindruck
Mit ausgeschaltenen Power
Save Funktion
War der ein bisschen schneller
Und ein bisschen stabler
Bisschen
Was hat das SATA Zeug eigentlich hier für Schmerzen?
Ach die Festplatte braucht wahrscheinlich einfach bis sie hochgefahren ist.
Okay, so als soll...
Oh, wie zu geleckt hat gerade.
Okay, ist wieder da.
Ja.
Äh, X.
Kill this. Jawohl.
Äh, so, iPerf.
Ey, was zum...
Alter! Was ist... Was ist mit
meiner... WTF?
Was ist mit meinen...
Memory Shortage avoided.
What? Der Firefox
hat sich ausgeschaltet gerade.
Die China-Chinesen
sind in meinem Firefox drin gewesen.
Aber heute ist Cursed, oder?
Wenn sich Firefox schon abschaltet
wegen RAM-Probleme.
Okay, das ist das gleiche
Geruckel wieder wie vorher.
Ich hätte da noch eine Idee.
Also das ist schon
halbwegs fein
von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Damit kann man leben.
So, wir müssen jetzt noch
Wir müssen jetzt noch
OMV mal starten, gucken, ob es in der
VM in Ordnung ist
Könnte auch in Ordnung zu sein
Okay
Chat, meint ihr jetzt, OMV
ist jetzt auch wieder schnell
Import
Start
Bam
Nicht das da, OMV
Root
Okay, OMV starten, zack
Ne, hier da
So, schauen wir mal
Ja, die Musik macht Stress, ne
Also
ist intens da sind super top secret passwort ipad bm guck jetzt ist es auch schnell siehst du
in wisse will falls noch da bist also es ist wirklich scheint echten back zu sein bei linux
mit der mit der version von dem treiber weil meine hersteller treiber benutzt dann ist es
auch in der VM deutlich schneller.
Gut.
Immerhin passt das.
Da bin ich jetzt zufrieden.
Was
packt das so rum
zwischendurch?
Ostchamp?
naja gut ist okay so jetzt ist nur die große preisfrage vielleicht weiß dass einer von euch
guck mal wenn man sich jetzt die die infos zu dem kölner modul von dem von der zertreiber ausgibt
habt ihr eine ahnung wie man sich anzeigen lassen kann das sind die möglich dass in der die
möglichen parameter von dem kölner modul habt ihr eine ahnung wie man sich anzeigen lassen kann ob
und was davon jetzt gesetzt ist
standardmäßig.
Weil ich hätte nämlich gesagt,
ich kopiere mir das hier gerade nochmal.
Pfunst oder so.
Weil ich würde gerne nochmal ausprobieren,
wenn ich in das Make-File
gehe von dem von dem neuesten treiber und jetzt hier nochmal sage wir schalten
aspm nur für die netzwerkkarte aus und ee nur für die über das hat ja auf jeden
fall nichts wobei das das kann man eingeschaltet lassen für die
netzwerkkarte aus oder wir können das einfach mit schweizmaus und dann mal
gucken ob das auch wieder probleme macht aber das ist das letzte mal mit dem
treiber ausprobieren ich heute noch am rade
aber wir wissen jetzt ja nachdem wir irgendwelche treiber geändert haben am
besten ausschalten hart ausschalten
Also, okay.
Also ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt,
E auszuschalten.
So.
Okay.
Den Sekunden Strom raus. Also was haben wir jetzt gemacht? Netzwerk haben wir ausprobiert,
Switch haben wir geupdatet, die Sachen mit ASPM probieren wir gerade aus.
Ich muss nochmal zu der Kiste hinter Strom rausziehen.
rf-programmer, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt.
Ich hätte sogar eigentlich einbauen könnte,
noch eine ältere Internet-Zweckkarte mit 10 Gig.
Die Internet-Zweckkarten taugen ja eigentlich ganz gut.
das einzige, warum ich da keinen
Bock drauf hab, ist, weil die ein bisschen mehr Strom
verbrauchen und
weil ich mir halt denke, den PCI Express
Slot könnte man vielleicht auch für irgendwas
anderes mal sinnvoll verwenden
und irgendwie widerstrebt es mir
eine 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte einbauen zu müssen
nur weil die Onboard
10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte sackt
das nervt mich
kann man glaube ich nachvollziehen, dass
mich das nervt, oder?
das ist halt ein 10-Gig-Nast und die soll
auch völlig funktionieren die zehn gegner zwei karte da sind wir wieder am start abhängen
backt bestimmt ja okay ist schon da sehe ich direkt ok zack ein paar gucken
wow alter jetzt übertreibt mal was jetzt los
was war das jetzt
das bestimmt nur fake
Alter, die Kiste
kackt schon wieder fast ab
Das liegt hier, das liegt eindeutig
Hier dran liegt das, dass der Firefox
abkackt, hier
an einem KVM Ding, das hat irgendeine
Memory Leak oder so
Okay, wieder gleiches Gependel
wieder vor, na gut
Was auch immer
Okay, macht keinen Unterschied
Mich ärgert halt, dass das nicht
Stable ist, aber gut
Wir kriegen in beide Richtungen ungefähr 9 Gig
Okay, kann ich mitleben
Pool Import
Vielleicht sollte ich das jetzt noch einmal
Ich muss das Skript hier packen
Okay, Open Media Vault starten.
Bam.
Gleich nochmal checken.
Also ich bin nicht hundertprozentig glücklich, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es ist okay.
Damit kann man leben.
Warum es jetzt aber ursprünglich so rumgebuggt hat, habe ich immer noch nicht verstanden.
Was war jetzt eigentlich das Problem?
Ah, es direkt per RJ45-Kabel an Switch zu stecken war das Problem.
Ah, 9 Gig.
Also wie gehabt.
ja okay geht klar
das ist in ordnung so dann ob media wollt noch mal ausprobieren und chat ich hatte
gerade eine richtig dumme idee die müssen wir auch gleich noch mal ausprobieren und
zwar mit der ssd der ssd was also ein paar gucken wir mal wie schnell das jetzt hier ist
ja okay flutscht halbwegs in der vm also okay ist jetzt vielleicht nicht die krasseste beste
performance ever witzigerweise die andere richtung ist gut aber geht klar
guck mal noch mal wenn man das jetzt hier gegen das nass machen
also nur dass ihr seht wie es gut wie es aussieht wenn es gut ist wartet mal
guck mal dass es viel schneller ist also dass ihr mal seht dass wie es aussieht
wenn es gut ist ich gehe mal gegen mein aktuelles nass mit einer ordentlichen
netzwerk karte drin guckt beim konstant ohne hin und her gilt gedingte 9,3 9,4 so muss so
so müsste das eigentlich sein 9,4 gig so müsste das eigentlich sein konstant in beide richtungen
das gleiche recht konstant so so so würde das aussehen wenn es richtig ist wenn die
Netzwerkkarte nicht sacken würde.
Aber Vergleich
mit der neuen Netzwerkkarte.
Ups.
Vergleich mit der neuen Netzwerkkarte,
dass ihr das auch mal seht.
Langsamer und
hat so komische Schwankungen
drin.
Kommt auch nur auf neuen Geek.
Quer.
jetzt sieht man es gleich ganz gut kommt kommt auch nur auf neuen gig also ist hier oben hat
man richtig sehen hier 9,3 9,4 und der hier kommt halt nur auf 9 und die andere richtung
aber brauchst du das wirklich das ist überhaupt nicht die frage ob ich das brauche ist dumm dass
nicht geht
also die netzwerkkarte ist auf jeden fall nicht die geilste
denkt so viel kann man doch schon mal sagen
ich hatte ich hatte eine idee für die ssd eine blöde es eine blöde idee aber
was ich mal ausprobieren will. Guck dir mal, ich hab
hier einen ZFS,
äh, ne, wie war das? Zpool
List, ne?
Status ist das.
Guck mal, ich hab hier, ne,
ein RAID 1 war's mal. Ich hab da die eine
Festplatte rausgenommen. Das können wir gleich wieder ändern.
Hier, guck mal, hier ist ein RAID,
ein RAID, also ein ZFS Pool.
Wir können noch die andere
Platte grad mal hinzufügen. Wartet mal, das machen
wir gerade. Ähm,
Dev, Disk.
Ist das eventuell ein Temperaturding bei der RJ45-Karte?
Wenn das Kabel direkt am Switch hängt, ohne SFP, synkt der dann gegebenenfalls...
Ne, ne, ne, der synkt immer auf 10 Gig.
Ich werde gerade genervt, dass wir zum Wertstoffhof gehen.
Okay, der Chat ist mit der SSD, müssen wir mal anders...
Wobei, wir haben noch Zeit.
Ich sage einfach, wir gehen 15.30 Uhr.
immer los
aber das nämlich mit der ssd noch ausprobieren
er 45 sagt ja es hat aber nur eine 45 steckern
was den x
was aber das witzige ist dass es
er hat 45 stecker
an ein SFP Plus auf AJ45 Modul
besser funktioniert als von AJ45 auf AJ45
Schau mal ob jemand alte PCs mit RAM wirft auf den Wertstoff
ich glaube also gibt zwei Probleme erstens
Glaube ich nicht, dass es einer macht.
Und wenn es einer macht,
kommst du ja da nicht dran.
Bescheid.
Mein Gott, tipp halt schnell.
Trägert euch das auch teilweise so?
Wenn ihr eine Antwort wartet,
ihr seht, dass der andere tippt
und es dauert ewig,
bis die Nachricht kommt.
Ich sag mal ehrlich,
mich nervt so unter Druckgesetze
einfach richtig krass, ne?
Frage, wann können wir denn los?
Hab ich gesagt 15.30, okay, Fragezeichen.
So, dann kommt als
Antwort, naja, wenn's
nicht früher geht,
aber dann kommen wir ab 16 Uhr in den Regen.
Ja, who fucking cares? Da kommen wir halt
in den Regen.
Ne.
Ne, nicht im Auto.
So, also.
Dann gucken wir mal.
Wo ist die...
Welche SSD hatte ich da jetzt dran?
Ein Terabyte.
Sorry, dann nehmen wir die da.
Gut.
Wie ging das nochmal? ZFS
ZFS Attach
Ist es Attach?
Z Pool Attach ist es, oder?
Attach
Ähm
Airpool
Und dann die hier, das müsste funktionieren
Oder?
Äh
Okay, ich bin
Zu dumm
ach muss ich die alte da auch noch angeben oder was ein terabyte
okay minus f
minus f
was will er
Was war ich denn falsch?
Leg ich nochmal durch.
Z-Pool Status.
So richtig.
ach das geht einfach so ok scheiß drauf z pool attach ich will dass in red 1 draus wird
also wie von stars
Oh, if you are attaching a disk to create a mirrored root pool...
Achso, Moment, muss ich vielleicht das Raid Level hier angeben?
ZFS, attach to existing pool.
Na scheiße, nochmal.
Attach disk.
Jetzt habe ich doch, genau das habe ich doch gemacht.
Exakt genauso?
Ich hab... Hä?
Muss ich vielleicht das da wegnehmen?
Muss da vielleicht das bei ID weg?
Ne, minus F ist nur für
Überschreiben
Hä? Was ist das Problem, Alter?
Okay, ChatGPT
Weiß bestimmt Bescheid
Oh
Chat, Chat
Ich hab Mist eingegeben
Ich wollte es zum falschen Pool
Attachen, dahin muss ich das
Attachen
ZFS, sehr gut ZFS, du hast mich davor
bewahrt, mein Root-Disk zu schrotten
Alles gut
Wunderbar
Siehst du, war
ZFS ist nice
Man denkt, es liegt an ZFS, aber es liegt an einem selbst.
So, jetzt haben wir wieder unser RAID 1.
Jetzt gehen wir mal nach Work, Save.
So, und jetzt machen wir hier FIO, mal den Test.
Hast du ECC? Jetzt hören wir mal los.
Leute.
Ich habe den Fehler gemacht, letztens Mikrocontroller-Forum auf dem Handy zu lesen.
Und ich wurde wieder hart getriggert von den dummen Leuten hier.
Ich kann euch, wenn ihr euch mal krass Rage baiten lassen wollt, wobei es ja nicht wirklich Rage bait ist, die Leute meinen das ja glaube ich sogar ernst.
Also wenn ihr mal ein bisschen Ragen wollt, wie dumm andere Leute sind, dann...
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Achso, der re-silvert noch.
Ah, der re-silvert noch, deswegen.
1 Terabyte und 2 Terabyte mixt, ja.
Weißt du warum?
Weil ich keinen Bock habe, mir eine neue SSD zu kaufen.
Der ist so lahm, weil er noch resilvert.
Okay, also
dann sage ich euch mal, was ich eigentlich ausprobieren will.
Also wenn ich hier
ein
guck mal, wenn ich hier einen Test drauf mache
auf das
warte mal, ich detach das einfach
wieder. Okay, ich detach das
wieder. Da haben wir jetzt einen einzelnen
einzelnen Pool und so und okay ist.
Oh, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es
kaputt gemacht. So, wenn ich jetzt
hier auf die SSD schreibe,
so,
dann ist ja...
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen,
Alter?
Jetzt sollte der eigentlich nicht mehr resilvern.
Oh, resilvering in progress?
Was?
Da sollte eigentlich nichts mehr resilvern?
warum die silva der da ist überhaupt nichts mehr drin
ok dann hätte ich das mal wieder ich will euch eigentlich noch was zeigen und zwar
administrator de ist auch paint champ ja ja ja das stimmt da hast du recht da habe ich aber
nie großartig gelesen habe ich schon damals gleich gecheckt das ist nervig
gehen wir müssen mal kurz das resale waren abwarten also folgende sache was
ich festgestellt habe ist wenn ich hier einen test benchmark auf die ssd mache
dann ist er so semi schnell also das ist quasi ein sequenzieller
Write mit einer Blocksize von 128k
ja hier auf die SSD.
Da ist er so semi-schnell.
Wenn ich allerdings mehrere Jobs gleichzeitig starte,
das ist ja bei SSDs auch so ein Ding,
dann flutscht das viel schneller.
So, und jetzt hatte ich eine richtig dumme Idee, Leute.
Ich habe mir überlegt,
warum
partitioniere ich nicht meine SSD
und
macht dann
Okay, ergibt das überhaupt Sinn, was ich gesagt habe?
Was ich jetzt sage?
Also ich splitte meine SSD in zwei Partitionen
mach dann ein RAID 0 da drüber
mit ZFS
und
und da drüber
dann ein RAID 1
und
und dann habe ich immer
quasi zwei Schreibjobs
und die SSD ist schneller.
Macht das Sinn?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert.
Ich glaube, das ist dumm, oder? Ich glaube, das lasse ich.
Das klingt richtig broken, oder?
Ja.
Ich gebe euch schon recht, das klingt richtig broken.
Ne, das ist, glaube ich, ja, ja, ja.
Das ist die Anzahl an Threads, das ist richtig.
Aber das Ding ist halt, wenn ich zwei Jobs gleichzeitig laufen lasse, die auf die SSD hämmern, die hat halt noch Kapazitäten, ja.
Guck jetzt, warte mal, hier, guck mal, Resilver.
So, da ist fertig, Resilvern.
Also, guck mal.
Bio mit einem Job.
So
Der bleibt auch so in dem Dreh rum
Wobei, wobei der grad krass langsam wird
Was ist denn mit der SSD los?
Ey, ich versteh dieses
Ich versteh dieses Nass einfach nicht
Was ist denn da jetzt schon wieder?
Okay, der hat einfach rumgespackt
Ne, das Problem
Bei den SSDs ist
Die
Nachdem da der Cache voll ist
Ist es halt nicht, werden die halt ein bisschen langsamer
So
Aber die sind mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen zu langsam
Ehrlich gesagt
So abfuck langsam waren die doch das letzte Mal
Sag mal, irgendwas ist doch bei diesem Nas voll für den Arsch.
Das ist jedes Mal anders.
Was denn funktioniert?
Die Realtek-Karte.
Guck mal, wenn ich jetzt aber sage, NumJobs 2.
Dann flutscht es, ne?
Droppt er zwar ein bisschen, aber...
Vielleicht liegt es am Netzwerk-Kartentreiber.
Jetzt wird es zwar langsamer,
aber nicht so langsam.
Ich check das ganze Ding nicht.
Das U-Creen
war zuverlässiger, aber die Hardware bei dem...
Also, ich glaube
auch, dass das U-Creen zuverlässiger ist.
Bei den Minis-Forums
finde ich halt nice, dass du PC-Express
reinstecken kannst und dass es ein bisschen
weniger verbraucht im Idle.
So ganz...
Es ist...
Merkwürdig hier auf jeden Fall.
Ja, und ich bin auch auf der SSD drauf.
So ist es nicht.
Wir können auch mal OpenSSL-Test machen.
Ja, ja, OpenSSL...
Äh...
Das 6800 verbraucht aber nochmal deutlich mehr Strom.
Das ist doch hier keine Geschwindigkeit für eine SSD, Mann.
Was ist denn das?
Nicht bei Apple.
Was ist das hier?
Ich komme mit G-Bated vor.
Und wisst ihr was?
Das Beste ist ja, dass wir es beim Testen das letzte Mal, war das noch schneller.
Warte mal, wir machen jetzt mal hier 4K, okay?
Job name ein.
Die SSD ist nicht voll, die ist komplett leer.
Oder nahezu komplett leer.
Das hier alles.
20650K?
Vielleicht ist mein Test doch einfach nur dumm.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich check's nicht.
Liegt das vielleicht am...
Habe ich ZFS zu wenig Speicher gegeben?
Modprobe?
ZFS-Conf?
Nö.
Nö, das ist okay.
60 Gig.
Ja, aber die FIO-Tests an sich,
die sind schon nicht verkehrt, weil guck mal.
Wenn ich die SSD
den noch mal die tätsche habt jetzt die tätscht jetzt haben wir mkfs xfs oder
sowas irgendwas was dann schön schön sag ich es so mount das danach mnt mnt und
jetzt vier werden geben
Na?
Ich mein, bei dem anderen ist ZFS drunter...
Moooo...
Na ne, okay.
Naja, bei dem anderen ist ZFS drunter,
aber...
Ah, der schwankt auch ganz schön.
Ist das... Ja, das ist ne 990 Pro.
seltsame namespaces die dinge können doch nur ein namespace oder können die mehr
scheren die beiden ssd sich lehnt angeblich sind das zweimal die ssd sind der eine ist glaube ich
zweimal nicht nur beide beides lot sind zweimal zwei oder so ich weiß es in 3 x 2 3 x 2 ich weiß
gar nicht genau 3 x 2 glaube ich oder minis forum in 5 er manual das glaube ich aber nicht dass sie
in einem pc express switch hängen das wäre komplett hängen geblieben das glaube ich dann wird man wird
man doch hier auch sehen oder?
Gab es da so ein Tree oder so was
vielleicht?
Gibt es da so ein Tree?
Es gab das hier, minus T, genau.
Ah, geil, perfekt.
Da weiß man natürlich sofort Bescheid.
Hier ist die SSD.
Ne, guck, die hängen nicht
hinter dem gleichen.
Das ist die eine, das ist die andere.
Okay, Canister Couple.
Wie gucke ich denn nach Namespace?
Habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Namespace ist so etwas ähnliches wie Partitionen, glaube ich.
nur auf nur auf hardware ebene
was sind auch so richtig so richtig schnell ist es halt auch nicht
auch aufs auch aufs xfs net
I.O. Depth.
Können wir machen.
Äh, was?
Was, was, was will er?
Ach so.
Dann muss man IO Engine Async oder so machen.
Na, äh,
Lip, Lip, Ayo, oder so muss man das machen.
Ja,
ist ein bisschen, bisschen besser.
Ah ja,
bisschen, bisschen besser ist es.
hier auf die auf das zfs auch ein bisschen besser naja wirklich das war das letzte mal
auch noch ich blick bei dem was echt durch das macht mich fertig das ding wir hatten das letzte
mal 1,3 oder so geek auf der ssd und das hier spackt jetzt voll rum guckt euch das mal an
Irgendwas ist da faul mit dem Ding.
Wenn man Sync macht, ist es tatsächlich sogar noch schneller.
Oder auch nicht.
Fuck, Alter.
wir gucken mal kurz was smart
sensors ob wir hier da ist die krebs vm
Ja, aber das ist ja...
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als würde das irgendwelche Probleme machen.
Guck.
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als hätte es irgendwelche Temperaturprobleme oder so.
Die SSD.
Alles vollkommen fein.
außer dass es lahmes fuck ist.
Okay, Leute, ich muss jetzt weg,
sonst muss ich mir anhören, dass wir nass werden
auf dem Weg zum Wertstoffhof.
Das muss ich mir auch nochmal angucken,
was die, was mit der SSD, was die SSD für Schmerzen hat.
Kann man jetzt nicht machen.
Mit Namespaces muss man auch nichts machen.
Mal gucken.
Power off
List
NVMe List
Okay, ich kopiere mir das raus
Das machen wir später
Machen wir mal die Kiste hier noch aus
Power off
Moment, ich kopiere mir das mal raus
NVMe List NS
Und Wobblos Domain muss ich auf jeden Fall
Erneuern gleich
Dann später
Gut, dann, alles klar, Leute
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart, ich weiß, komische Zeit
zum Streamen
Aber wenn ich schon mal frei hab, dann hab ich frei
und dann ein bisschen gebastelt
Wir sehen uns, macht's gut, bis denn
See you